it is such a public thing with the
ratings and I'm even going back to you
came in here when you were first
starting yeah you got there really fast
no no but yeah I know but you know
a girl a drink or anything you go
straight to this but but here's the
thing I feel like you're enjoying your
there's a looseness now there's oh yeah
I mean you just do it for a while I've
never done that before I mean I've never
been on camera as myself this was I mean
I don't know why I didn't think it would
why I didn't think it would be
excruciating I don't know but I
completely because I'm I'm an actor I've
been an actor my entire life and I was
an actor on The Colbert Report and then
to like turn that off and just go out
there stand by a joke with no character
in front of you was excruciating for me
to do to learn publicly was very
difficult there's a weird learning
process you're on 11 30 at night you're
taking over for Letterman I mean let's
go back in time sure and suddenly now
you've got to figure this whole thing
out in one night you know it's it's
tough yeah it feels like that it feels
like every night you've got to figure it
out tonight right you know but then all
those little nights add up they you know
those Pebbles turn into a boulder and
you go oh yeah oh we're running
we're rolling downhill you know you came
on the air CBS is pinning a lot of hopes
and dreams you've got this great
reputation everyone goes oh Steven's the
smartest and the funniest the next thing
you know a couple of months later all of
a sudden Stephen's out James Corden is
going to be the the new late night host
and then James Corden how to deny it and
say they're not going to swap out times
like you were going to go to 12 30 he's
going to go to 11 30. yeah it's always
like Panic that you wouldn't do well I I
didn't I never believed that that would
happen you didn't no no no CBS is like
that is not gonna nobody said that to
you no no they said the exact opposite
like that is not going to happen right
it doesn't make sense because you've
just invested a lot of money in this guy
and you don't want to seem like you've
been with it I think it would have to be
years it's not impossible I think it
would have to take years of not
delivering for that to happen when I
think about the trajectory of your
television show and how it has become
this force uh it's it's a political show
and yet it's still fun force is a strong
one well it is these shows are always
about what the conversation is today
right that's one of the things that I
learned is that the old show we actually
not that we broke news but the old show
we would actually educate the audience
to an idea we were interested about like
I would do 20 months on super Pacs or
politics like that that's not this gig
no this gig and I enjoyed learning this
is this is what are what is everybody
talking about water cooler conversation
what are people worried about today what
are people excited whatever it is like
okay I know you've been thinking about
this all day this is what we thought I
think you've identified the number one
thing that a late night host has to be
uh really up on which is that water
cooler conversation and that's where I
think you really found yourself you
expressed a definite point of view you
weren't wishy-washy you weren't trying
to take both sides no I don't have any
responsibility to take both sides my
responsibility to give you in my opinion
you see but like the Johnny Carson era
and the Merv Griffin here no matter who
the president was it was always sort of
very middle of the road that was more
indicative of the country yes I mean
this all all entertainment that
Americans enjoy is always a reflection
of what America is like right now
Stephen what happens when uh the Late
Show becomes number one and it starts
winning on a weekly basis does life at
CBS
celebrate every week that you win the
ratings yeah yeah there is a celebration
well it's Pizza I'm not paying for it
I'm telling you I understand but I'm
saying there is a celebration honest to
God I don't like reading any about
the other guys because I know it's like
to have that written about you
right and I don't I respect those cats
you want them to do reasonably well but
uh listen we went into this just to be
in the hunt you know we just say like
look if we're just in the hunt every day
like they win one we win one that's
great just so we are like I feel I feel
gratitude to CBS and it is it would be
ungrateful to not not to try how about
that right and so to be in the hunt is
fantastic to be winning on a weekly
basis well that's just wonderful
foreign